hi I'm here with Pete cumin he's a
co-founder of Optimizely Pete can you
tell me a little bit about what
optimized he does yeah we make it easy
for our customers to optimize and
personalize the experience they give
their customers on their website or
mobile applications fantastic and what's
one of your favorite memories from early
on and Optimizely
there are a lot I think probably the the
one I'm most proud of is when we helped
the clinton bush haiti campaign raise a
lot of money for earthquake victims in
2010 so Dan my co-founder and I were
coming off the back of to startup
failures and we had just started working
on Optimizely
and we were building an easier way to
run a be tests on your website and a few
weeks into the project we got a call
from somebody on a newly set up
organization the clinton bush haiti fund
that was created to try and raise money
for the victims of this horrible
earthquake in haiti and they had one
beleaguered IT guy i think who built
this website and was struggling to keep
it up
and they were getting hundreds of
thousands of visitors every day and they
called us because they had worked with
Dan on the Obama campaign in 2008 and
they wanted to improve the website they
wanted to earn more money for these for
these earthquake victims from the
website and so over the course of
several days we barely slept at all
we built the the beginnings of our
platform and then we ran a bunch of a B
tests on their website what I mean by
that is that we took a look at their
website and we came up with hypotheses
of how could we make this better and
maybe it's adding an image of earthquake
victims you know next to the credit card
form or changing the layout or making
the text more readable and after a whole
bunch of these experiments we were able
to measure that this particular change
actually improved the the conversion
rate this one harmed it this one
improved it and we're able to actually
raise their their dollars per I ball
essentially by 10% and so we actually
helped them raise an extra million
dollars for the victims of the
earthquake that's incredible